Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my Flash Episode 3 video.
Lots of groundwork for Legends of Tomorrow
being laid that we'll talk about once we get
to spoilers.
I'll just go ahead and say that now, Careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet but will do as you start with top five
moments then I'll explain there are some Easter
eggs for Smallville in this episode as you
may have picked up on it just because some
of the actors in it were also in small though
in new round of the reverse flash ring giveaway
starts now all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so here we go starting with number five
meet Captain Cold and golden gliders father
played by Michael Ironside in the context
of the TV show he's an actual person like
they bring them on in the comics usually the
characters are much older so their father
is a strange psyche he is a nonissue just
floating around somewhere in the ether or
he's dead the TV show version of the character
very true to the spirit of the comic book
father is his job to humanize Captain Cold
laying the groundwork for legends of tomorrow
for him to be this antihero because as we've
seen before is really closer to being a villain
that a change things in the comics all the
time during the new 52 though golden glider
is very much a rogue she's every bit is evil
is Captain Cold I a note evil is a relative
term but she's as much of an antagonist is
he is in this episode she actually seems very
genuine but do not be surprised if she totally
pulls the rug out from under Cisco exit got
on my number for Cisco in golden glider is
now the most interesting relationship on the
flash and even though that is not like an
actual relationship a lot of moments between
characters are nonverbal moment so like the
way she touches them the way he looks at her
the way he rushes in to try and save for before
before they messed things up in the lab and
then said the bottom off accidentally if you're
not a big fan of this relationship stuff don't
worry the not like beach over the face with
that is not to be a big thing because Lisa
started enemy in every single episode but
I just feel like there somewhere that Cisco
has like a secret picture overheard like you
know he had that picture that he got of him
in the Canary lassies and he's using the super
fan boy for everybody I feel like he also
has a secret picture of golden glider in his
wallet is awesome is the Captain Cold scenes
were this week especially with Michael Ironside
being so amazing it being such a vicious character
if you like the scenes with Cisco and golden
glider were way more fun and who else is noticing
the theme of guns when we have rogue episodes
like what is it about you and guns Cisco you
should see my nerve collection like anytime
Captain Cold or the rogues are an episode
gun technology is a big thing visually of
a part of her conversations with Cisco about
having a bad father Leonard taking care of
her also kinda bleeds into the other storylines
to like Barry talking to Joe about locale
I turned out I turned out this way because
you raise me things could've gone very differently
so like you Captain Cold probably would not
have been a villain if his dad would've been
so awful but you can change that you can make
different choices you not to be defined by
your past you see Heather like the laying
the groundwork for a big reveal I think that
zoom's character is going to time to this
theme to but the biggest thing in this episode
is really just setting Captain Cold up to
be a hero when legends of tomorrow starts
so that is like the bigger storyline than
the zoom storyline is the big themes and episodes
apply to all the characters in all the storylines
so course on a number three Joe tells Iris
that her mother is still alive this is actually
a pretty pretty shocking reveal her mother
Francine was a drug addict Joe sent her to
rehab after she OD'd one one of many times
that she had problems with drugs like just
the last time that he sent her to rehab she
took off and just disappeared so that explains
a lot of Joe's scenes with Francine like what
you you're what are you doing back here you
don't deserve to be in irises life this is
basically going to be irises big season-long
story arc healing her family season one was
about Barry trying to heal his family you
know get his father to prison save his mother's
life season to get to be all about fixing
irises family which do you feel like throw
some more fuel on the fire that is the theory
that zoom is a West you like a Joe West or
is Wally West I really rather he be Wally
West because it's like you know Barry being
the child is like I want to fix my broken
family would be amazing if Wally West had
the same thought that he didn't have the same
type of parenting that Barry had so he turned
out batlike instead of becoming a hero he
became a villain that is a theory what to
put on the shelf we still have enough evidence
yet we haven't got our Wally West reveal but
we did get some foreshadowing of the beginning
the episode this scene where Barry is messing
with the beaker when Iris calls them and he
spills it if you've never read the original
Barry Allen silver age comics Wally West was
kid flash so what they did is they had Wally
go to Barry's lab where Barry got his powers
rigidly you know but that of the chemical
spelling you getting struck by lightning and
Wally West was involved in the exact same
time of accident and became kid flash you
were costume just like Barry's the first until
they changed it and made it yellow and then
he only started wearing the red costume again
after a crisis on infinite earths out after
he'd grown up and he took the mantle of the
flash what they've said about Wally West on
the TV show now and we haven't seen them yet
obviously an episode that they been referring
to him as kid flash so he will be younger
than grant Gustin on the show but I don't
know how young will be because the actor playing
him isn't that much younger than grant Gustin
in real life the speaking of earth two onto
number two Jay Garrick is ready to go home
now using the speed Canon what a catchy name
for the earth two portal the funny thing here
is just like the parallel storyline think
he and Caitlin have with Barry and Patty into
they have like the awkward me cute moment
where Caitlin stalling to get Jay Garrick
to stick around longer you guys can let me
know like who you think has more chemistry
at this point to the that Barry and Patty
who are just like dork twins or do you think
that Caitlin and Jay with slightly more traditional
personalities when the actor the place Jay
Garrick was talking about his character like
becoming Jay Garrick use like I'm trying to
bring this old world sensibility to the character
from the comics even though on the TV show
he's a much younger character like you raise
someone in his like maybe early 30s so whatever
they do these like relationship he scenes
most of the awkward humor is gonna come from
Caitlin's character with Jay Garrick and then
Barry and Patty just cannot take that awkward
dark energy to hyper speed to finally on my
number one WTF Martin Stein full lips out
and gets ready to fuse a new firestorm matrix
with the Jay Jackson character and Harrison
wells of earth two comes through the portal
let's go with firestorm version 2 first that's
gonna be the next episode is pretty self-explanatory
they find a match for the firestorm matrix
someone that's compatible so that they fuse
it helps keep Martin Stein from dying we we
can talk most about that next week so that
next week will be a heavy firestorm episode
but Harrison wells from earth two I saw Lottie
you guys freaking out about this on twitter
so here's the deal the look on his face here
yeah I looks a little bit evil but earth two
Harrison wells isn't going to be the exact
same character as Harrison wells from Earth
one the reverse flash Harrison wells he will
be working with the characters Tom Cavanagh
is a series regular he's going to be in most
of the episodes in season but he is just like
a super ass hole character is not evil he
just a super big Dick part of that I think
is to make Martin Stein seem more likable
because right now he's really short with people
is just not quite as friendly as some of the
other characters as star labs and I feel like
Tom Cavanagh the actor in real life does much
better when he's playing characters that can
be somewhat unlikable he's is a really good
job of making unlikable characters seem really
likable is one of the hardest things to do
is an actor like you're playing a character
this really unpleasant but your job is to
make the audience love you I think you guys
are really gonna like the character of the
season Tom Cavanagh's awesome is even more
awesome when he gets to be like a little bit
evil without actually being evil let me know
in the comments though how far out do you
think we are from a Wally West reveal is I
feel like irises mother's going to be like
okay I was away for 20 years while I was away
I also had this other child who to show up
in town and then Iris will have to deal with
them like okay you know I don't know who you
are but you're part of our family now Iris
just seems like the type of person who would
be really quick to bring people in of the
family even even though she will have her
WTF moment WTF is his brother I didn't know
I had just explained the really big small
Easter egg they had it like a really awesome
small boat joke in the episode when Barry's
introducing himself to Michael Ironside he
says might my name is Sam that's no march
to Michael Ironside who on small Ville played
General Sam Lane, Lois Lane's father and Lucy
Lane's father who was played by Peyton list
who is Golden glider on the TV show so Michael
Ironside was her father on small boat he's
her father on the show now to both very terrible
dads if you guys and see it I name the reverse
flash ring giveaway winner from last week
in my Star Wars trailer videos to just rewatch
that video if you haven't already I'll put
a link in the description is is that I'm moving
to a new apartment this week in there was
so much Star Wars stops I wasn't able to get
the Q&A video out so hopefully that will not
be the case this week but I will be posting
a new Gotham video from this week and new
agents of shield that they'll just be a little
bit later this week the normal story still
posting all the regular stuff and I will I
will do like a room to her video my new apartment
like was actually get furniture in there white
as way for everything to watch the Star Wars
trailer again like 10 billion times and here
for all my flash arrow videos thank you so
much watching everybody high five and see
you guys tonight!